are you sick of all these destiny to
rumors wouldn't it be nice to just get
something official well your wish has
been granted i'm tony and this gamespot
news update is getting a sequel we've
known for a while that a new destiny
game was in the works but an official
name and any details have been scarce
then some posters leaked revealing the
name as destiny 2 and teasing some sort
of beta possibly coming first to ps4 q
the official destiny twitterccount which
tweeted out this picture confirming the
name as simply destiny too as for
details we know you won't be able to
port your level or gear over to the
sequel though you will be able to
transfer your actual avatar and be sure
to subscribe to gamespot for any more
info that trickles out destiny 2 is
currently slated for launch this year
with those leaked posters suggesting a
sep tember release date maybe we'll get
a proper trailer and release
announcement at e3 in a few months for
now you can check out the latest episode
of reboot for more shooter RPG action
with Mass Effect Andromeda
[Music]